わぁ　折れたった
こんにちは　はじめしゃちょーです
はい　というわけでアメリカから
帰ってから@#$%はじ
ちゃんと言おう
はい　というわけでアメリカから帰って参りました
はじめしゃちょーです
というわけで　先週一週間ほど
僕はアメリカに行ってたんですけども
何をしに行ったかという話でございます
行った理由としては
まず映像関係の勉強というのが
ほぼ間違いではありません
毎年アメリカのカリフォルニア州で行われている
VidConというイベントに参加してきました
2010年からやっていて
今年で7回目らしいです
もう　YouTubeファンとかクリエイターとかの人がね
何万人も集まって行う巨大なイベントでございます
まぁ　そのファン用のイベントとかね
こう面白いイベントとかもある中で
もうかたわらではクリエイター用の勉強会みたいな
マジな勉強会みたいな感じで
講義みたいなお話をちゃんと聞いたりして
いろいろわかったことがあって
勉強になったこともたくさんありました
基礎的な部分も学べたんですけども
まぁ　それ以上にこうYouTubeに関してね
うぇ
そうだったの
え！？
@#$%&*
みたいな　ちょっと驚くような内容もあったので
まぁ　今後そういうことをね
どんどん活かしていければいいなと思っております
とりあえず
一番驚いたのは日本以外の人が結構見ている
そしてそれにあわせて僕もちょっと　こう
いろいろやっていかなければなっと思っております
世界のみんな待ってておくれ
200個くらいいろんな講義があったんですけど
そんな中でピックアップして
授業みたいな人受けることができたりして
まぁ　楽しむとこは楽しんで
勉強するとかしっかり勉強して
大変ためになるアメリカでの一週間だったと思います
YouTube中の偉い方がいるんですけども
その方のスピーチを聞いて
その中でいろいろなんかね
今後のYouTubeに関する発表があったので
それは僕がちょっと皆さんに今回伝えようと思います
えらい
海外だと結構みんな知ってるんですけども
日本の皆さんは多分VidConと言っても
パッとこないと思うんで
そこらへんはちょっと皆さんに
今回お伝えできればいいなと思っております
まずですね
YouTubeクリエイターセンター
というものができたらしいです
まぁ　このクリエイターセンターという場所
簡単にいえばチャンネルの成長を
サポートしてくれるらしいです
こういう感じですね
もうページーができてます
おっと　関根が...
関根さんがいますね
あぁ　僕もいます
ありがとうございます
ごちそうさまです
まぁ　このクリエイターセンター
何があるかと言いますと
YouTubeで　こう
どうすりゃ成功するんだろみたいなこたが
何か一ヶ所にまとめてあるらしくて
もうそれを見るだけでグッディらしいです
他にもYouTuberで　こう
情報が交換できたりする
スレッドみたいなもんがあるらしくて
そこで皆さんでお話がすることもできるらしいです
まぁ　僕がやり始めたころは
YouTubeなんてなかったし
ん？YouTubeあるわ
どうすればいいかどうか何もなっかたんで
本当になんか手探りでやってたんですけど
何か困ったことがあると
すぐサポートーしてくれるらしので
まぁ  YouTube簡単に始めるようになったなと思います
もうひとつ
ここからが重要です
何とYouTuberが全員
色付けされるらしいです
まぁ　ピンとこないと思います
ちょっと説明しますね
何かね　こう
チャンネル登録者数=
その戦闘能力みたいな感じだったんですけども
それがもっとわかりやすくするためにですね
YouTuberが全員色付けされるらしいです
さぁ皆さんは何色なのでしょうか
こちらですね　出発点はグラファイト
すべてのクリエイターに
ご参加いただけますという訳で
もうアカウント持ってる皆さんはグラファイトという
レベルらしいです　今はね
できることが開放されていくみたいで
グラファイトだったら
クリエイターアカデミーという
場所で学ぶことができたり
クリエイターツールでチャンネルの管理する
そして　チャンネルの収益化のサポート
受けることができるみたいです
グラファイトの次はこちらです
オパール　1,000人から1万人
オパールになるとYouTube Spaceで
イベントやワークショップに参加することが
できるみたいです
交流会とかにも参加できるみたいですね
次　1万人から10万人のクリエイターの皆さま
ブロンズ
ここまで来るとすごいっすね
アンバサダーどかYouTube Spaceで
何かできたりするんだね
こうじょうちょーさんだ
失礼しました
そして10万人以上
僕じゃないすか
10万人以上シルバー以上という色付けになります
実はですねYouTubeのチームから
僕を何か担当してくれてる
パートナ的なマネージャー的な方が
実はgoogleにいます
いつもお世話になっております
という感じですねチャンネル登録者数
というものはただの数字ではなくて
その数字によって
できることがどんどん増えていてて
それがわかりやすくなったというわけでございます
で　今回の発表ですごいYouTubeが変わったなって
思ったことが一個あったんですけども
もう全員がですね
YouTubeのサポートースタッフから一日以内で
メールが返ってくるらしいです
本当かな
サポートースタッフがですね
何かこうメールでわからないことを問い合わせると
一営業日以内に必ず
こう何か受け取れるようにするらしいです
いやー　すごいよ
これでわかんない事があったらすぐ
もうYouTubeさんに聞けますからみんな
という話です
一週間すごいいろんなことがありました
映像を含めYouTubeのことも勉強できたし
英語もね　しゃべる機会があって
何かもっと勉強したくなちゃいました
そして初めてのアメリカ
今まで見たことがなかったものがいろいろあって
またアメリカ行きたいなと思ってしまいました
ま　ひとまずYouTubeどんどんこう
皆が使いやすいように変化しているので
もうね何か昔と比べてね
YouTuberみたいな
動画を出すようなことが
すごいしやすい環境になったのかなと思います
何かね　こう日本だとね自撮りしてて
しゃべってるとちょっと
おかしな人だと思われるんですけど
もうvidConの会場とか結構
みんなカメラと話している人が多くて
もうやっぱアメリカでYouTuberでいうのが凄い
浸透してるなって思いました
という感じです　はじめのアメリカレポート
まぁいろいろ勉強になったんですけども
まぁそれを活かしつつと言いつつも
まぁ適当に楽しくへらへらっと
今後もやっていこうと思います
以上　アメリカからのレポートでした
じゃあな
超まじめ
あ　今殺そうとしませんでした
そんなことないw